you're wearing your Apple watch Julie
you're very excited i got these tweaks
what do you think i am thrilled like I
like my excitement level has just gone
up I'm a swimmer I think this has been
one of the things that's been missing
from these smart watches I think it's
awesome I would like to contrast this
with ohm who's wearing his old-fashioned
watch does today I know you tried the
Apple watch it wasn't for you just an
analog person lookin a step from a
product perspective though you know how
important is this for Apple yeah I don't
know how to swim so wrong guy you're
asking these questions hi this is all
new insides Lili reengineered hardware
perspective how submit well again I
think it's it's about getting this thing
to be a standalone independent device
and they've got a long way to go to do
that I tell you the biggest news in my
household is that you can play pokemon
go on it my year 10 year old is going to
be lobbying for a watch for his birthday
pretty soon well niantic saying that the
Pokemon Go app will be shipped before
the end of the year so you know given
these changes Julie do you think we'll
see watch sales tick up like is this
what the Apple watch needed for a little
kick you know I think you know all of
these bits help you know we have about
one in five consumers a day that have
some kind of a wearable device we're
forecasting that to be about one in
three within the next four to five years
and yeah I think it all adds up right me
and maybe pokeyman go does become that
killer app that you know gets 10 and 12
year olds to want to buy this device and
the maker of Pokemon go niantic CEO John
Hanke has been on stage let's take a
listen to what he had to say this
morning were really excited to show you
something new that we've been working on
it's designed to seamlessly blend
Pokemon go gameplay with your daily walk
or run while enabling you to focus on
what's important all the cool stuff
around you Pokemon go on Apple watch
oh yeah i think the gaming is a big
opportunity on the on the watch you know
we are investors in a company called
everywhere in finland which is
developing and doing pretty well on on
the on the on the app on the watch and i
think people want to interact with a
much smaller screen so i'm actually
pretty excited about what pokemon does
to make people think bigger about gaming
opportunities our interaction
opportunities on the watch and i think
that not only just for Apple that will
push the whole industry forward there's
also of course the fitness possibilities
that this you know new waterproof
feature opens up Ben de hairen of
creative strategies and analyst who will
be joining us actually later today says
that waterproof was among the top
requested feature for the Apple watch
the swimmers Julie included ya know it's
you know I but I think this is always a
hard market right this is a new product
and I think it's also hard to ask
consumers what they want I think this is
going to be one of those categories
where Apple needs to show consumers and
Samsung needs to show consumers what
makes these devices so magical